glad you're here Maria because Maria
knows how to handle you have you have
good people around you because you train
good people around you okay before you
got here Brad Williams gets here mm-hmm
and our staffer is trying to set up the
camera in the Jets hat handsome Rob
right they up so like he's somehow less
of a person Rob just walks up behind
Brad moves his chair while he's sitting
here no no he didn't move the chair he
moved my shoulders oh my grab my
shoulders you ever see the office when
ricky gervais moves the girl in the
wheelchair that's what he did that's
what [ __ ] rob brandi tell me you went
I can't ride the real ones it's the
biggest thrill I can get well that one
out well now I got these Nikes that have
like a three inch lift great by the way
with all the stuff about Americans
disabilities acting like I need a ramp
how can they do that if you fall off the
roller coaster no I'm just kidding how
can they not force them to build certain
cars that little people can go into
chapter 2 of dwarf against that nothing
happens every amusement park will have
to do it you need to start filing
class-action lawsuit yeah against
[ __ ] rides that won't let you all you
got
I'm gonna be the dwarf Jesse Jackson yes
my first act is to find dwarf accessible
podiums Brad suggested a book he just
mentioned a book called dwarf etiquette
and the writer said a couple of really
funny things about like this that's a
hilarious book that great best-selling
author yourself Maria don't you think
that's a good idea I would totally buy
it best-selling author I am what's in
your book
well the ever girls guide to life the
Everett girl's guide to diet and fitness
looks plural and I just missed the last
one neighbor girls guide to cooking you
missed what though cookies I like a few
is like the most wine in frustrating why
didn't you do every girl's guide to
brain tumors
how are you brain tumors for dummies
yeah I don't know but maybe maybe she
could write a book for you called brain
tumor etiquette our turn we're good
she'll curse at me later in the hallway
what beat you on the list you when I was
that when I wrote I've been many years
there's one book on the list that like
for me the secret was I was like I'm not
[ __ ] budging this book what was the
one that was like right ahead of you or
to a head
I honestly all I remember is something
called Hungary there's something with
Hungary in the title I can't remember
cuz that was number three with the first
one hungry for laughter that's a book
I'm working on yeah hungry for Lester
the fork in front of an audience good
stuff the comic cookbook hungry for
laugh is Johanna making evil laugh I
mean it's the one benefit of having a
swollen head book just missed the list
this one just missed
yeah cookies a hard one because you
can't get a lot of crossover for a
cutlet dude Girls Guide to do this that
but the cooking is a ruffle that was
tough yeah I was so frustrated cuz you
know person you love
do you like numbers and tracking things
and do nothing
I don't normally but because I made the
list with my first book after that you
get spoiled
next one can't fail Billy Bob about how
he won an awards for Slingblade so early
yeah but like everything he did after
that that now becomes the standard
Billy Bob Thornton told me that you're
on the plane with him on his way so
lovely he
I was going to sit in my seat he was
sitting behind me and he's like Maria
turn around I Billy and we'd like met in
the lounge and walked together because
we're all friends with his manager Geyer
and and so I was like hey let's party
like you bump into people I was all
alone hoarding a cheeseburger in the
lounge and then I saw them and I was
like perfect timing I'm probably good
[ __ ] on my teeth yeah but on the plane
he's like weary and I turn around and
he's like you know you interviewed me at
the Four Seasons I think and we've
talked a few times and and you were
really good he like he was complimenting
me on my interviews and I was like
that's so nice like when people take
time yeah actually remember and they
want to tell you you did a good job I
asked him what he was he was in the last
week and I asked him about slim by like
you think you'll top that because you
can't compare what you've done to what
you're doing now because people are
always gonna go with the older I'm
Harrison yes yeah you should have asked
a former and well if you ever Top
Armageddon let me come on
that's true yeah you weren't here for
the interview it's not true yes it is
you weren't in the studio well no way
we're out that day was stolen radio host
Valor you want compliments on your
questions that you didn't ask thought
the counts right
you sit with him or or were you guys
separating he was behind ok thought I
had my pod we were does anybody a dick
to you during interviews no because
you're so nice like is anybody like
whatever you interview people there's
always some people that don't give
information and they're difficult like
do you run into that at all especially
your interviewing actors who are very
protective yeah I definitely had like a
couple people that were really really
mean that just me wanted to make you
feel stupid yeah yeah I saw your
interview with Tom Hanks and you're just
like why and then actually one person
apologized to me years later it was
really male or female you know what did
you say I was in a bad mood that day I
have to ask my USB Drive Kevin we can
call her salon with her and she
apologized to me and was like really
nice when she said I was an [ __ ] and
I'm sorry it's probably something like
wow remember
do you've any idea why a person the guy
why would a person promoting whatever
they're promoting be mean in an
interview well ok so there are so many
different factors one they've now talked
to 20,000 people that day right and
they're annoyed some people just aren't
good at press like we take for granted
that work good on a mic and we can like
do our thing and be uninhibited and not
nervous like actors some of them are
real just true actors and they can only
be bold in that light that makes sense
and so some of them just aren't good at
that I'm not comfortable yeah and then
now imagine if you're like new at
interviewing let's say are younger and
you're a little nervous and you might
ask them something that they don't like
being asked like a stupid question like
those entry questions like so tell me
about them some of that stuff you have
to do to break the ice sometimes and and
sometimes you've heard that question
like you know what was it like to work
with Robert De Niro in the film you have
to like they say the price up from I got
called glib by Tom Cruise he's like
you're being glib Jim stomping Matt
Lauer
what it wasn't you money that's my
center he's not the only thing he has in
common with Matt Lauer can I just
clarify the button thing okay because it
has bothered me for a long time yeah
breaking news right here every major
executive had a button it wasn't just
mellow oh okay lock the door
my dad said when he heard this through
he was like yeah I mean every executive
I've ever been around his head a button
that shuts a door and it's just because
like you have you have meetings with
people and it could be bad news it could
be whatever and you're not gonna get out
I've never heard that two seconds to
shut their door they all had buttons he
wasn't the only one it was a make that
sound like it was a terrible trapped
place they did a story on ESPN that Nick
Saban has that in his office too like he
has the money Saban the coach of Alabama
yeah yes he's like yeah that was
literally installed in every other funny
how that story became like that's the
first reference I went to and you said
Matt Lauer yeah but I don't know why
that became like a [ __ ] focal point
yes the sad thing about some of these
things right so like that made him seem
like a huge predator obviously there
were things that you know took place I
don't know anything about what went on
what didn't go on whatever but that was
the focal point that's right and the sex
toys in the closet books were like a
gift from somebody as a goof like
remember they told you the sex toys in
the closet yeah they do remember that
but yeah but you're right like they
weren't like used yeah I've had people
on the show on my shows that have
brought me sex toys Maria brought me
edible panties no edible doctor what it
was Kevorkian
clarify the strawberry panties they're
delightful dr. Phil impression everybody
I thought he was gonna try to give me
the reference the USB Drive thing but he
said that chip needs a coffee table book
for sure kevin has been very very
proactive in his ideas are good he wants
to do the coffee table book I think he's
right I just tell you all day every day
at home it's like it's too it's that's
chill so I now say it too that's why I
wouldn't show business is being tortured
by this nonsense Keven Undergaro will
call me and be like here's your chip
needs to do and I'm like Kevin I'm not
in control of chips destiny you're lucky
you can call Jim okay here like your
husband is literally everyone's manager
like not yours that everyone so crazy
his brain is so good and it's always
like he's always thinking oh I think you
always think like and it's good that you
had that access to somebody
yeah thinking in so many different
directions yeah right about him and you
know I've you told him it's not true but
you like you know he gets like stressed
out you get has stuff going on and I'm
like Kevin and so like I'll go to I'll
go to like lunch with him or whatever
and he's like no I'm just gonna have
grilled chicken and some string beans
and I'm like Kevin if you stop being
everyone's manager all the time and stop
worrying about everybody except for the
people who are actually your loved ones
you can eat whatever you want
nope it's because you're too stressed
about too many people you're building
podcasts to because for Joey Diaz yeah
that's right she didn't people in your
life
yeah narrow it down to the people who
actually care about you and you care
about and then have all the pizza in the
world he just has such a passion to help
people he really loves it like he really
lives for it yeah
I said to him the same thing I'm like
have you got to be a little bit more
strategic here like you're just giving
gifts away and some people not to
mention any names aren't really
appreciative I take it they're
appreciative in the moment and then it's
like mmm crickets like Kevin loves
helping except then when he kind of gets
treated like a piece of [ __ ] later are
people she doesn't feel good would they
take it for granted because he likes
doing it so then it gets taken for
granted yeah and then he feels shitty
because exactly so it happens all the
time yeah but that's what happens people
like to help you mean like people are
just like oh no they like this so you
know that helping me is their reward - I
don't need to acknowledge it I just
might my I can't express my joy it
didn't occur to me that's chill I didn't
I didn't know you were you didn't
recognize your own catchphrase it's not
mine it's his that would be like me
looking at Jaleel White and being like
did I do that and be like huh you guys
got it right yes okay this is what you
have to realize the monster you've
created there's a man that's laying in
bed next to Maria Menounos and is
giggling because he's got his little ear
buds in and he's laying in bed next to
Maria Menounos watching chip podcast
yeah the fact that that's infiltrated
somehow this very legitimate show
business life swell with pride it's so
great the other thing that you guys are
into very much Anil your I've heard the
stories
the Purina people are outside having a
[Laughter]
we were talking about dogs earlier of
course talk to us about periods
purplish approach what a beautiful
transition yes Maria I mean you want to
talk about having a 70-pound pit in the
house that's my dog have you met Maria's
dog well which one you never did
meet max I think I was probably
terrified to introduce you to max no he
saw he saw me walking into your studio
and like that like cool chew toy he was
in the window barking at me and you're
like we can't have you meet mad [ __ ]
puppy
[Music]
[Laughter]
he is so protective truly like bipolar
in that way he is a lover with us the
few people he trusts which is literally
like five people and everyone else he
wants to he's a killer how big 130
pounds he's huge he's a massive Jeff I
love dogs
and I went into the house the first time
I met him and we were like we were
walking around house me camera walking
around the house and he stays whether
it's Kevin or Maria max is by their side
hmm and he was cool with me and he liked
me and I was like this is good but he
has this way about him where he's
looking like exactly and he's waiting
for pets and if I put my hand down his
eyes changed and it's like oh my god if
I don't keep showing this dog affection
he's gonna turn yeah and there's nothing
I can do to stop if you can somehow get
that dog to maul say she was kind Kevin
we have to like work really hard to do
the intro to get him to be nice so my
cousin's came into town to do family
feud recently and I introduced everybody
I was like doing the intro and I was
like nervous and everyone seemed calm
and then my cousin who's like six feet
tall goes in for the hug oh that was
chasing my cousin with hydrogen peroxide
um I bend over Pete he broke skin
someone get that sound back please there
was a little so I was like oh my I
identified the area I'm no longer
looking at your ass and I'm like patting
him down
Wow so he like how do you know how do
you break someone into it okay this guy
is gonna be around the house for a
couple days don't attack what do you do
to break him in a dog smells bitter we
have to like completely keep him
separate from people like but if there's
people he'll there's just a way it
takes it's a lot of work like if I was
at your house with Kevin ting you how
would I get the dogs or not a time if I
want to pet him don't want to pet the
dog you can't do that we have to do that
how would you guys do they have to work
very hard to let him know that you're
okay but then he's gonna look at you
with a third eye the entire time and if
you come close if you're even taller or
whatever it is if you could use just
something normal like go to you know
touch her back or something he's just
going to like tell you right away the
way I do it as I shake the owner in
front of the dog we're friends establish
dominance monster yeah I wanna see a
picture of you in German Shepard he is
my everything we rescued him from West
Side German Shepherd rescue he's changed
my life saved my life in so many ways
because I've always been so afraid and
in real life yeah and and you know we've
had a lot of robberies in our
neighborhood and so he has brought so
much peace because I know that the
second anyone enters that property they
are going to see max in the windows
literally salivating for lunch like
they're gonna do you have a sign that
says there's a problem yeah oh yeah and
the second you walk in you will see the
door block shots in the NBA with those
bars I would win them over the animals
love me they there beyond they can't
help themselves
please max max would find me charming
excel max and I would get a lot
also you hear I'm laughing nice dog this
love brings you to the Purina yeah
purple Isha so project so not only that
but like I've worked for years to raise
awareness about domestic violence and of
course being a crazy animal lover this
project was really dear to me because I
don't know if you guys know this but ten
percent of shelters in this country will
accept people with their pets so imagine
you're in a very scary situation a one
in three women will experience domestic
violence but one in four men as well and
so you want to take your whole family
there you don't want to leave anybody
behind and that includes your pet and
with only 10% of shelters accepting that
means half of survivors are staying in
abusive situations we can't have that
because they want because they want to
be with the dog
no never never with somebody abusive
that was quick she's tripped over me
twice so they can bring what is this
they can bring a dog with them or no so
well that's the thing so the purple
leashes project was created with Purina
in partnership with Red Rover to change
that so purine has committed a half a
million dollars in grants to help make
shelters safe for pets and this way
people can bring their pets like we were
renovating one in Maine recently and I
interviewed this woman because I'm gonna
do an entire episode on my podcast
better together for domestic violence
month coming up in October it's why I'm
sporting the purple and she said how
could I leave my dog he literally jumped
in as her boyfriend was about to murder
her literally was she was seconds away
from being choked to death he saved her
he attacked that the man he loved he
loved
yeah and he attacked him and protected
her she's like how could I leave my dog
in right situation so we want to change
that and we want to fix that and
obviously Purina is amazing to commit so
much money to this and so part of the
project is we're trying to raise
awareness so we're encouraging people to
social so if you just social a picture
of you walking your pet which I brought
two leashes I need another one I'm gonna
give you this one yeah they pets well
you could walk Sam social a picture of
yourself walking your dog tag
Purina hashtag purple leashes project
and you know that's its it'll be good
together that's a really good cause yeah
I'm so dumb and unobservant ID you
walked in with two purple dog leashes
and it didn't occur to me to ask why you
had them and then the the good part by
the way Jim your interview stolen valor
valor now you're it woods already become
my favorite because a lot of people and
most people have been very calm I've had
a few jerks I mean it's part of it yeah
only like who have you interviewed that
spin I don't want to say hasn't been in
here it has been in here I had somebody
apologize to me recently really I was in
a Barbara and they apologized they came
up and they said they were sorry I
wonder what he's gonna say I said when I
[Laughter]
use a purple leash Lyla Garrity I want
to get a dog but I live by myself and
I'm lonely and I know how to take care
of it if you live by yourself and you're
lonely those are reasons what you're
acting like that's reasons no no no but
I travel I plus I have a cactus no I
want to get a dog I would love to have
that a brownout
for 130-pound but I want a dog that
menaces everyone on sight there's not
the bite people you need a poodle dog
funny people already wondering about me
do i need an affirmative it's a yes
folks literally everybody sees you with
a tiny little bag dog that's how I would
be great I took it everywhere well no
because poodles are just so there
they've got so much personality man Jim
I've got it I know you travel a lot
mm-hmm emotional support dog yes yes
like what Satan you you would be the guy
that has like a weird emotional support
animal like like this is my emotional
support skunk
yeah small pony that the woman brought
her yeah yeah Shetland pony or as my
people call them horses little Satan
will say now I'll get a little bag dog
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app